yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here of bleach report and for today's
video we are checking out every nba
team's top three trade deadline targets
article here by greg swartz so the
criteria for this article is gonna be
all three nba teams are gonna be giving
a target to being a dream target
realistic target and sneaky target so
let me know in the comment section below
based off your favorite nba team uh who
are your targets based off this criteria
like as a piston fan sneaky target i
would love to get like a buddy healed he
would work nicely with like a kate
cunningham realistic target um it seems
like we get like wayne ellington every
other season so i can see that happening
again and then dream target
probably a time machine that would bring
back you know grant hill prime of course
you know pre-injuries so yeah a guy can
definitely dream here but we are going
to be starting off with the atlanta
hawks and we got ben simmons for dream
mark is smart for realistic and sneaky
of gary harris so the theme here is
definitely defense uh offensively the
hawks are like second in the nba so you
know all these guys right here are not
like demanding when it comes to the
offensive side of the court but uh even
a guy like ben simmons is going to help
increase the pace just the ball movement
and really just overall the defense of
the team so
yeah all three of these guys really do
make a lot of sense marcus smart in the
back trey young definitely works and
then gary harris um you know he's had
not the greatest last few seasons but
he's been pretty excited this season for
the orlando magic so definitely a sneaky
pickup right there um next up we do have
the boston celtics and we got john
collins erigor and ben mclemore so with
john collins it does give them you know
that three-way score type of power
forward um giving them a big three of
jason tatum jalen brown and also john
collins which i think just works uh then
eric gordon you know gives him a veteran
type of dude out there that once again
can play like a third option i feel like
that's kind of like the going thing with
this right here is that you know they're
looking for guys that can give you
productivity behind tatum and
uh also jalen brown but in a very like
efficient type of way then ben i mean
he's a guy that can score the basketball
so adam to the team you can get it for
cheap sure why not
uh next up we do have the brooklyn net
so here we have jaaka purdle dorian
finney smith and mike muscala i would
absolutely love jakob over on the
brooklyn nets he's exactly what that
team needs just that defensive anchor in
the middle uh dorian finney smith is one
of those switchability type of players
that can play multiple positions and
doesn't do anything like spectacular but
does everything pretty solid which works
in a you know star-studded type of
lineup and then mike muscala you know
big guy that can shoot a little bit so
uh
yeah it doesn't give you probably the
defense you want at that center position
but floor spacing is also a pretty solid
thing to have when you have james harden
kyrie and kevin durant on your team uh
next up we do have the charlotte hornet
so we got three centers listed right
here miles turner who is the guy that
obviously offensively speaking is the
best of all three of these guys and has
the defense uh nerlens noel has the
defense plays on the inside and then
robin lopez is like a cleanup type of
dude you know veteran that's been around
for a while you know what you can get
out of them but yeah they can pull off
miles turner that would definitely be a
big time i know another guy that was
just listed as somebody that could
potentially be going for is actually
another um trade for ben simmons so ben
simmons at center for the charlotte
hornets definitely signed me up for that
assuming the trade is right which uh
based off daryl mori i mean yeah they're
gonna want like lamela ball and lonzo
ball and lavar ball and probably also
toss them liangelo at that point right
man so all the ball brothers in exchange
for ben simmons um and of course levar
who is the father uh next up we do have
the chicago bulls with a dream target of
jeremy grant realistic target of larry
nance and a sneaky target of nicholas
batum
so by doing this they're looking for
some sort of consistency at that forward
position you know with having guys like
patrick williams be out and uh derrick
jones and just really a lot of injuries
to the team so yes dreamery grant can
help carry the scoring load right now
but also provide the defense needed um i
do like larry dance he's also another
one of those like four words that just
does a little bit of everything out
there um i would also love maybe like a
dorian finney smith in the situation or
a veteran and thaddeus young and then uh
yeah batum was a pretty nice player for
the clippers last year so uh corner
three type of guy that could play some
defense uh next up we do have the
cleveland cavaliers and we got a dream
target of brandon ingram realistic a
character liver which they actually show
great interest in and sneaky target of
goron dragic
so ingram gives them like that go to
plenty uh 20 plus point per game score
at the forward position uh with charis
you know you get a guy that can handle
the rock but also play off ball a bit
and then goran draczek who's just a good
solid veteran point guard um kind of the
ricky rubio replacement for the rest of
the season which we all know how
important he was to the team before
going down with that devastating injury
uh next up we do have the dallas
mavericks so what type of star can we
find to put next to luca doncic and
chris hopps porzingis we got a dream
target of christian wood now a front
court of christops and wood uh would
just be so dynamic like having you know
six 10 plus guys out there that can
literally score from anywhere on the
court uh would be fantastic uh buddy
healed that's actually a really good
realistic target man [ __ ] because
he's one of the better three-pointers in
the nba and uh we all saw you know when
they had like seth curry on the squad a
few seasons ago playing next to lucas
just how nicely that worked out for him
and then kemba walker very nice contract
um
we know when the right system the right
moments can definitely be you know one
of the better point guards in the nba
yes injuries have caught up to him over
the past few seasons but uh you know
he's not asked to be charlotte horn it's
kind of in this case if he could be like
a third option score behind luca and
chris stops that's a big time w for the
dallas mavericks um next up we do have
the denver nuggets a very uh
injury-riddled team this season so we
got a dream target of derrick white who
can realistically play you know with uh
bones monte jamal murray when he's back
from injury can come off the bench be a
scorer so love that pickup for the
denver nuggets i don't think it'll
affect chemistry too much over time uh
robin lopez just a backup big guy behind
jokic and we got dennis schroeder who uh
once again like a few cents to go on the
okc thunder he was like the best backup
point guard in the nba so in the short
term gives you that scoring push
you know as they make a push for the
playoffs and trying to get a higher seed
um and then once jamal's back it's like
schroeder can be a sixth man he actually
excels at that spot so definitely makes
a lot of sense next up we got the
detroit pistons and we got a dream
target of mo bamba i think last i heard
they were talking about wanting a first
round draft pick for him uh i would
definitely do a future first round draft
pick from obama just kind of try him out
i really think that um he would just
give you know kate a really like dynamic
player to play alongside with uh
realistic patrick williams i've been so
sold on him uh for a very long time man
well going back to summer league like he
just looks ready to blast him into a
star once he's back from injury and we
got a sneaky target of kyle kuzma aka
flint's finest um he is from michigan
and uh yeah he's been amazing for the
washington wizards and uh he's kind of
been linked to the pistons for a while
now man you know going back to last
season everything on the lakers
next up we do have the golden state
warriors so we got kendrick williams who
is um a very just good value contract
somebody that can provide spacing but
also some defense so he fits in writing
with the warriors right there mike
muscala
talked about him in uh earlier just a
center that can provide some spacing
which works instantly in the warriors
type of offense then we got marcus smart
with him and curry in the backcourt like
that just is beautiful um playing with
klay thompson at times i mean he would
probably have to be a six man which is
definitely okay
but uh yeah mark is smart he could be
that difference maker on this warriors
team going forward if they do decide to
trade for him
next we have the houston rockets so uh
here we have ben simmons derek white and
rui hachimara so really by getting ben
simmons on this team it's kind of a way
you know
to take that next big step as the
rockets franchise i mean
you're looking at a core of ben simmons
and jalen green and i really think that
can work so
i don't know what that would mean for
the future of kevin porter if they would
definitely put benjamin to the point
guard spot or maybe try like a forward
spot but uh you know ben simmons is an
all-star player he is not old and uh
yeah i do know the asking price for him
is ridiculous but uh you can pull up a
nice trade it's definitely worth going
for and yeah with derrick white
rouhamira just two veteran guys that you
add to the team there that uh can play
multitude of positions
and uh it's not gonna really disrupt
chemistry but also bring you some good
solid talent uh next we have the indiana
pacers it's gonna be interesting because
they're kind of like this like we might
want to go into rebuild but also not
totally quite sure so here we have a
dream target of gordon hayward um
i think it was the last nba trade
deadline or during the offseason there
actually was a proposed offer of gordon
hayward for miles turner so we could see
something like that being revisited uh
you got dorian finney smith and luke
canard um you know luke adds some
three-point shooting to the team jordan
finney smith talked about him just a guy
that can fit in anywhere on the squad
essentially and bring you something so
yeah uh definitely not a rebuild type of
move so this is definitely more of a
retool type of scenario
uh here we have the los angeles clippers
and this is going to be jonas
valachiunis nurkic or kemba walker for
three different trade targets
and uh with having kawhi leonard and
paul george out
this is essentially just like doing
something right now to
you know especially kemba walker we know
that offensively he can carry a team
right so that would be nice in the short
term but in the long term um any of
these guys you know fit is like a third
or fourth option on that clippers team
once they get completely healthy so yeah
i really like all these moves especially
that lechonis like he's a very
underrated center um he would fit
perfectly next to kauai and paul george
next we have the los angeles lakers so
we got a dream target of eric gordon who
just gives him that combo guard that can
really play the one through three um and
give you that bulk scoring out there we
got kendrick williams talked a little
bit about him earlier three and d type
of guy and then lou williams who uh
definitely does not help the age of this
squad but uh yeah i've really seen lou
williams do too much as of late so i
would personally probably stay away from
him no disrespect to him he's one of the
greatest six men guys of all time but i
don't really think that helps the lakers
too much
in the short term i definitely want to
see them pull off something big
especially in the sneaky category uh we
got the memphis grizzlies so we got a
dream target of jalen brown uh realistic
of robert covington and we got marvin
bagley for a sneaky target okay so with
jalen brown i think one thing to
consider right here is you know you got
to give up something to get something
and i love just the direction of this
grizzlies team so much that would be a
little hesitant to pull off a big time
trade to get like a jalen brown because
that really can disrupt chemistry and
it's kind of like if it ain't broke
don't fix the type of scenario now i
think you like a steal for him obviously
you do that
but uh man i like the direction of this
team right now uh next up we have the
miami heat and this is gonna be dorian
finney smith tory craig and paul millsap
yeah any one of these guys uh the miami
heat i think are a pretty deep
basketball team in general and uh yeah
they just gotta get completely healthy
and they'll be good to go so none of
these guys are going to disrupt
chemistry but uh give you that veteran
you know type of player that you can put
in as you need them uh next we have the
milwaukee bucks so we got a dream target
of nerlens noel realistic target of
dougie mcbucket and we got jalen smith
for a sneaky target so looking at the
dream target right here of nerlins noel
um you get that defensive inside
presence that you normally would get
from a brick lopez now lopez also does
space the floor a little bit millions of
noel is definitely more of a traditional
inside type of guy so you lose some of
that right there but uh yeah i actually
really like jalen smith just for like
that energy type of guy off the bench
maybe like that mantra's herald type of
role going forward and then make buckets
you know adds the uh spacing
we got the t-wolves uh oh gee oh yo og
next to like cat that definitely works
man he also gives that scoring because
it seems like they always try to go for
like these type of like forwards have to
be like roko from the past or even like
jared vanderbilt right now that can
bring you that defense but you really
want that guy that can also kind of have
the uh defender on the other side of the
court just kind of second guessing being
like i probably should not leave og open
and that's going to prevent less double
teams i like the karl anthony towns um
then larry dan's jim michael green yeah
so some more forward type of players in
this case
um next we have the new orleans pelicans
we have a dream target of darren fox
realistic target of colin sexton and a
sneaky target of taylon horton tucker uh
dear fox is the great point guard i
don't know if i love him next to zion
because of his you know lack of a really
like reliant type of jump shot but
at the same time i mean if you are new
orleans you have a chance to go for a
star player you probably do it
i'm just thinking in this case you're
probably looking up giving up uh brian
ingram to do so
and i just don't know if darren fox and
zion is that much better than you know
ingram and zion for the long term now
colin sexton um i like his jump shot a
little bit better he brings the defense
out there i think he could be more of
that second or third option on this team
and then tht once again you know
defensively makes a lot of sense
offensively speaking um i think it does
leave a lot to be desired you know in
the long term
uh next we have the new york knicks so
we got the jonte murray oh i love that
man just like that near triple double
threat out there that doesn't have that
large ego to him um that it would be a
championship type of move uh goran
dragic veteran point guard for this
season then reggie bollocks who's been
on the knicks before i believe um you
know sits on the three-point line and
space things out nothing wrong with that
uh here we have the okc thunder so we
got gary trent mo bomba sergey ibaka um
searching back it doesn't make a ton of
sense to me uh my opinion on derrick
favors on the team already is that they
are a rebuilding team that should
probably use those big guy minutes to
you know man use on like a guy that has
a lot of potential like we kind of know
who sergey baka is uh gary trent makes a
lot of sense next to shaquilles
alexander but i would love mo obama on
this team he would be given such a great
chance to really shine um not saying
doesn't have that chance on the magic
but you know with having like wendell
carter on that team and everything even
mo wagner as of late um that's been
pretty solid it's like you know he would
just he would get to play 40 minutes a
game over on the team here uh here we
got the magic speaking of them patrick
williams jetty osmond kelly uber jr so
yeah with jonathan isaac's injury
history it's like it's hard to really
know what the long-term plan for him is
so this just gets you especially in
patrick williams of a new young forward
to try to really showcase
uh we got these 76ers so bradley beal
bogdan joe ingles um some more spacing
next to joelle embiid would love bradley
beal they can somehow get bradley bill
for ben simmons uh they will be my
favorite to win the championship playing
the simple
um next we got the phoenix suns with
josh hart thaddeus young harrison barnes
so love harrison barnes the sneaky
target has a championship ring with the
golden state warriors um you know was
part of that dominant dynasty team and
everything so you put them on
the uh the suns and i just think that
really makes them even more elite than
what they already are
portland trailblazers miles turner
derrick white mitchell robinson
so some more guys especially in derek
white's case this could kind of be a
signal of maybe um
you know getting rid of cj mccollum over
time because with how on foreign
assignments has been you add derek white
to the mix you got norman powell who can
play the guard spot uh obviously damian
lillard when he's back from injury like
somebody has to go but miles turner
mitchell robinson gives him something
different at the center spot from a
nurkitch so yeah sign me up for that
uh here we have the sacramento kings
with sabonis in harris or nuwara i'm
sorry wara of the milwaukee bucks
and uh this is basically the king saying
no we do not want to go in a rebuild we
want to go into a retool we have dear
fox on this team let's try to build
around him again uh some bonus or to buy
his harris like supposed to be amazing
man like i would just love him as like a
second or third option on the kings
going forward him and darren fox had
pick and roll like she would be amazing
to watch so yes love that
um next we do have the san antonio spurs
so pj washington evan fournier chris
hopps porzingis really zoned in on pj
and chris tops in this case because uh
you know greg popovich obviously has his
ways of coaching like after coaching as
long as he has you're not gonna switch
it up too much but uh this definitely
puts them even farther step forward into
that new type of like arrow basketball
we have been in where it is all about
you know having the unicorn you know no
pun attended but maybe in a way um type
of big guys in chris hops porzingis or
even a guy that can space the floor give
you some great shot blocking in pj
washington
uh here we have the toronto raptors with
yaakov mantras kobe white
love mantras or yakub on this team i
would actually realistically i would
probably like mantras a little bit more
man just that high energy type of guy i
think would work really nicely in the uh
raptors type of system and then kobe
white combo guard that can play a fred
vanvleet gary trent jr whatever really
lineup you need them in he can
definitely get it done give them some
good scoring
uh we have the utah jazz with uh jeremy
grant justin holiday and goga
um jeremy grant him and rudy gobert
elite front court to defense but also
that third option type of scoring
actually no i guess he would
realistically be the second option
behind diamond mitchell in this case so
uh yeah i love the combination of him on
that jazz team fits their system then
finally we do have the washington
wizards for john collins eric gordon
grant williams um this wizards team is
so interesting because they do have just
like a very like
large amount of these switchable type of
forwards on the team you know with ruby
hatch and mary denny avia um john
collins would be a way to maybe
consolidate some of that talent and get
like an actual all-star caliber guy that
you kind of know who he is at this point
so i could see them doing something like
that but uh that is gonna be the end of
this video here guys so hopefully you
all enjoyed let me know in the comment
section below what your dream realistic
and sneaky targets are looking like
thank you all so much for watching and
peace out my friends